so a family get torn apart Pamela
Anderson is speaking out for the first
time about her ex Tommy Lee getting
knocked out cold by their son Brandon
Pamela calls the situation going on
right now with her ex-husband Tommy Lee
a quote matter of life and death
explaining that her 21 year old son
quote punched him in the nose for all of
us who he has hurt now Tommy feels
humiliated and is attempting to destroy
his own son this is the devil this is
the disease of alcoholism the allegation
of alcoholism was raised yesterday by
Brandon when he told people he was
planning to stage an intervention for
his father Tommy denies he has a
drinking problem he released a lengthy
statement to ET saying quote do i drink
yes do I drink more than the average Joe
yes no matter how much people want to
pin me as this deviant alcoholic abuser
that isn't me Tommy says Brandon punched
him because he was upset with the way
Tommy reacted to a recent interview
pamela gave about their marriage he's
unconscious and his mouth is bleeding
Tommy Lee's fiance Brittney placed the
9-1-1 call Monday night a source tells
DT that Pamela and Brittany do not go
long adding that Pamela has quote no
intention of speaking with Tommy until
he stops partying
Pam raised the boys for the most part on
her own and that Brandon wants to quote
help him live a clean life and to mend
their troubled past but Tommy never
seems to change end quote
[Music]